and when the movie came out it was
instantly great i mean it was instant
instantly profitable
and one of the coolest things about it
was i didn't even release it for people
to
rent or purchase
how much money was going into your
movies when you were dealing with the
financiers
um you know we we always made sure we
didn't spend more than a hundred you
know we never spent more than a hundred
i really
unless you're shooting with
massive names
or if you're shooting something that of
course
if it's something that is going to use
up most of the budget like we i just
finished working with someone who's
doing a film where you know it's
dinosaurs and
it's a very different thing right so so
a lot of money is going to go towards
you know cgi and all that stuff so
um
but if if you're shooting the kind of
movies that i shoot that rely on
practical effects and you know things of
that nature
and the stars are not huge and stuff
like that i don't believe it should go
over a hundred
i believe anytime you're going over 100
you're really rolling the dice i think
you're rolling in dice anyway but you're
really rolling the dice over a hundred
because
i believe that with a
smart marketing plan even with a bunch
of flaws um
you can make back a hundred
if you go to 250 you go to 350 and you
don't have huge names attached
or if you don't have a whole lot of
marketable elements
you could you could dig a hole that you
can't climb out of
so it's always been under 100 and i try
to keep most of my movies under 100. and
if you factor in a lot of the
the discounts i receive on things
you could really see my budgets kind of
coming in at around 250.
you know that that's what they would be
like if i was being charged full rate
for a lot of things
and so 100 sorry for the entire
production including posts and
deliverables and and
prints and advertising yes okay
and were all those films profitable that
had financiers attached
i would say that
in the beginning
no
they didn't they became
they became
more profitable after i got them back
and after i marketed them myself
the reason being is this and that's why
i just gave up one answer a one-word
answer of no and
the reason is because
earlier on i thought
if i give my film to
a distributor
then that distributor is going to market
my phone they're going to sell it all
over the place and then i'm just gonna
break in a bunch of money
and
it'll be awesome
and that's not really what happens a
distributor
basically places your film
and
if no traffic gets driven to those
places you don't make any money
so ultimately it's your
job your responsibility as a filmmaker
to drive traffic to that film
or to to drive traffic to those places
where it can be purchased right or
rented or whatnot
so if you're not doing that you're not
making money and if you this i mean back
in the day when sales agents really
mattered um
that sales agent could take the film and
sell it here and sell it there and sell
it there but
nowadays that doesn't really matter
unless it's a huge film or it has a very
huge name attached even though those
things don't matter so you have to
understand
not only that it's your responsibility
to do so
but you have to also understand how to
accomplish it how to drive traffic to
those places so that you make money so
no when those films were released
they were not profitable then but they
are profitable now
so it's not just enough to get a
distributor to put it on itunes or
google play or whatever you've got to
have a plan in place to get eyeballs to
go to those links correct correct that
was that was one of the biggest lessons
i had to learn and not only learning
that that was my job
but figuring out how to do it
because it can be very tricky it can be
very tricky because
the the amount of films that are out
that are constantly coming out is just
crazy and if you think about it as as
filmmakers most filmmakers think
oh this person's in the film this part
and all these people know other people
and everybody's talking about my film
amongst each other oh man i'm doing it
it's huge and it's like no because
you're just talking to other people in
the industry
and yeah everybody else in the industry
is talking about it but
they're really not your audience and
they're really not the people who are
going to make your film a success
they're not unfortunately the audiences
the people who you're marketing the film
to in terms of a paying audience who
that's their interest
that's that those are the people who you
want to be aware of your film
those are the people who you want
talking about your film
and
as i began to notice it more and more i
even took my own personal
facebook page down i took it down
because it was
for what i was doing it was worthless
and it was a waste of time because
everybody who i knew worked in the
industry and we all pumped each other up
and oh you're awesome and that stuff
doesn't matter that stuff does not pay
the bills you know pumping each other's
ego up is that's all it's doing is
pumping you pumping each other's ego up
so i got away from that completely and
started really focusing on how do i find
my audience
and how do i keep them engaged
and then how do i best convert that
audience to a paying audience how do i
best do that
and those were things i just learned
along the way
so maybe your audience let's say
would be
the people that would attend a horror
convention in middle america
rather than people on either coast that
are also looking to be cast correct okay
but unfortunately and you don't know it
really on on
on like when you're on like a me social
media platform like facebook
everybody's friending you friending you
like oh my movie's so popular
and it's only
after you
sit back and you look at it that you
realize man every single one of these
people are either actors or composers
like
what is this like i got 7 000 friends
well i have
5 000 friends and
4 thousand and 800 of them
are other actors and composers
you know like that's that's the the list
of uh and that's not my audience that's
not who i'm really looking to
to convert you know those are the people
who i'm looking to keep engaged
they're already engaged because they're
looking for work
you know
so
you know i had to learn how do i
how do i find my audience and how do i
keep them engaged how do i keep them
happy
and
i really started to notice when i got ax
man back and i just kind of put out a
blurb about it guess what guys i got it
back
and then everybody was like oh that's
awesome blah blah blah
and what are you going to do now oh i'm
going to re-edit it oh you're going to
re-edit it how's it gonna be different
and people were actually really engaged
and and we had a lot of back and forth
and i had people writing me you know i
always thought this should have happened
in the movie and i'm like we already
shot it it's like it's
i'm re-editing but i'm not going back
reshooting things you know it's been a
while i think everybody's aged at this
point but um you know just looking to go
back and re-edit it and then get it
closer to the vision that i had for it
and they were just so excited and
engaged and when the movie came out it
was instantly great i mean it was
instant instantly profitable and one of
the coolest things about it was i didn't
even release it for people to
rent or purchase i released it directly
to
amazon prime and 2btv
and that was it
just those two just those two platforms
now it's since expanded
but just i would even say even if you
remove amazon from the equation which
you know
if most
filmmakers haven't
they should
in terms of av or in terms of svod you
should remove that from the from your
overall vision of how much money the
movie's gonna make
and really focus on places like 2b
because that's where i would say
95 of the revenues come from
has been from 2b
and with 2b are there forced ads
yeah yeah so you you have to watch the
ads sure you have to watch
and and i think every movie it starts
with like two or three ads and then it
goes into the movie and then a few
minutes in it's another four or five ads
and then they go and so
if you keep people engaged if you have
quality content you keep people engaged
each time they pass one of those
commercials you're making more money and
so you know that's the name of the game
is is avod for for certain movies for
certain movies now if you have a movie
like you know like the my most recent
film one-to-one if you have something
like that where you have you know a
couple of names that are in the movie
that people recognize that's something
you want to really push and see
what tvod has to offer transactional
video because
the odds are a lot of people will go
there to rent or purchase that film uh
because they recognize those people and
because the content may be something
they're interested in
did you use an aggregator to get it on
to be or
amazon prime or these other
you said uh with the v
sorry with the watson want you yeah yeah
yeah uh with
the smaller films i go through filmhub
actually
filmhub is a great resource um because
mainly because i i think
for most people the barrier to entry is
too high
from going with a traditional aggregator
because they're going to charge you per
platform they're going to first of all
have a set fee and then any platform
after that is another fee and another
fee and another fee and another fee
right
now if you anticipate
and when i say anticipate i don't mean
hope but you you've actually done the
homework
and you anticipate making
i don't know
uh
500 grand right unless i'm just going to
use that ballpark figure if you
anticipate making 500 grand from your
film and you went through an aggregator
then you paid them up front
so that's all they got so if you paid
them if you paid them up front and it
was
2 500 bucks
then that's all they got and you got all
the rest of that money
but if you went through film hub
well film hub you didn't pay anything up
front they take
i think it's i think it's 10
so if they're taking 10 then they took
50 000
which is huge
but
if you anticipate because you've done
the research and you know films in your
certain budget range they maybe only hit
a certain number
then and you know that you're gambling
anyway
then film hub is better because there's
no real barrier to entry you can just
put the film in see how it does and
let's say you you crap out at ten
thousand right game's over it's made up
it's made ten thousand and from now it's
petering out
um
then you didn't spend anything to get
into the game and if you if film hub
takes their percentage they've only
taken a thousand dollars
is there a period of time when the film
kind of peaks
or it depends on the title
in terms of like viewership is it the
first month
i think it all depends i think it
depends on your how you've promoted the
film or if you even know anything about
promoting
because
i didn't in the beginning and i know my
film came out i know people were
watching it
but i had no idea how they were watching
it
um
i never sent them anywhere to watch it
it grew a following but i i don't know
how much of that was
how much of that was from them finding
the actual places where it was being
shown and watching it through there or
just watching a pirated link i would
have no way of knowing
because i never i never invested the
time in understanding how to market to
an audience
so i didn't have that
information at my disposal
but
you know as i
as i
moved more into understanding the
marketing of a film
i can say that
i usually will
feed that audience engage that audience
and then
point them to where i need them to go
and i can watch the film through every
quarter actually with film hub because
you know you can piece out the rights
you can you know take the rights and do
this by yourself and then filmhub only
handles this but of everything i'm
seeing i can see it month by month
what's happening
you know and see how much money i'm
generating how many views i'm getting
month over month and i usually find that
in the first quarter that's where you
get
the larger number of people viewing your
film because that's when it's still hot
that's when it's most exciting and
everybody wants to watch it and see what
happens
and then it starts to kind of
find
a little medium
and it rise that probably for another
two quarters
and when you say peace out the rights
what does that mean meaning you own it
in perpetuity but then they
own it for a certain time certain amount
of uses no actually film hub doesn't
they you're not even
you're licensing it to them but it's for
no predetermined amount of time
so at any moment you can just stop it
you can say you know what i'm not liking
this anymore i'm just going to stop it
now
and you can choose to do so
and what i mean by piecing out is
you know if you're going to i mean it's
different now but in the beginning if
you wanted to keep
amazon rights for yourself because
ultimately why would you want somebody
to upload to amazon when you could do
that yourself
so for a lot of people they kept the
amazon rights themselves
and then they would put the rest of
their
you know the rest of the platforms on on
filmhub and then they would make all
their money that way
and so
as
amazon has moved away from allowing
direct uploads for a prime
they've moved away from that recently so
i say recently like it was just now but
i think it was
beginning of 2021
they they moved away from that model so
yes you can upload your film and it can
be tv od for rent for purchase
but it won't go to amazon
prime unless it was put up by another
distributor or an aggregator
really do you know why they did that
i mean the rumor is that
it was because so much of prime was
cluttered with
not that quality content because people
were saying oh it's a feature film and
really it was just a bunch of episodes
of uh
uh you know something they put on
youtube like you know like like uh you
know them um what was one of the ones
that was like a tutorial on
something like nails and stuff or
something they just put together a bunch
of episodes and it equaled out to like
45 minutes and they just uploaded that
and now that's considered a movie and so
i think amazon just they got enough
backlash from that
and they decided you know it's it's not
worth it for us to allow people to do
that now we need somebody curating that
content i think that was part of it i
think the other part of it too is
ultimately amazon creates their own
content
and so
you're even though i know i know a lot
of people think that
we're not really in competition with
with amazon because
you know they have these huge big shows
that are watched by hundreds of
thousands of people if not millions of
people we're not competing with that and
essentially yes you are
you just
not you
by yourself
but if you and you and him and her and
we all got together and there was a
thousand films that hit amazon prime
if you add up
all the people watching that content it
is rivaling their
shows is taking attention away from the
stuff that they've created
so i think it's those two reasons
in tandem
that really pushed him to make that
decision and say you know i think
let's put an end to this let's make it a
curated thing where
at worst i'm sorry at best they're going
to have to go through
through film hub
you know and and i think so many people
still don't know about film hub
and i think if you if you knew about
film hub
as a as an independent filmmaker
you would never rely on
another predatory distributor again you
never would because you realize they're
completely inconsequential you can give
your film away to this guy over here who
will make money off your film and you'll
never see a dime or you can do it
yourself and put it on film hub and
chances of you saying money is far
greater
you know
it would keep people out of making some
really bad
bad deals with
distributors with bad intent
you know
and do they have certain specs that they
require aspect ratios yeah
yeah yeah yeah they they do
they do specify the the formats that you
must submit and they do specify you know
how many moments of black you know that
you can have so that the films are
pretty uniform so you're not having more
than i think
more than
two seconds of black at the beginning
and not more than two seconds of black
at the end that sort of thing just so
that movies start you know because i
know there are people who try to pad
things out and oh you know if i throw on
two minutes of black at the beginning
and
five minutes of black at the end you
know my movies now
83 minutes
so i think they try to do that but but
ultimately it's just something to keep
it uniform
why have you put your films on 2b
at the moment it's probably the greatest
revenue generator
because people get to watch it for free
it's a free
app that's
in pretty much
i would say almost every
english-speaking territory and even some
non-english speaking territories so it's
widely available uh just as much so as
amazon prime and
you know it's it runs off ad revenue so
it's completely free unlike amazon prime
where you have to have a membership you
know whatever you pay per year your
annual membership with 2b you just
download the app to your phone or to the
computer or to your television and
you know you're able to watch films
completely for free just everything all
the revenue is generated from from
advertisements so
we recently heard that a filmmaker
said that he made like six figures
from tubey um
can you tell us your experience
uh six figures yeah definitely possible
i think it depends upon
a lot of factors i don't know if this
filmmaker did it on one film because
that's a different set of factors versus
he just had a bunch of his films on
there and that's a different set of
factors but depending upon the factors
yeah certainly
all that really all that really needs to
happen is that you drive an audience
that you've been interacting with
to to be
you know the only the only
pushback i would say i received in terms
of of why someone hasn't viewed a film
of mine on 2b was just that they didn't
know what 2b was they didn't know how
much it was going to cost so they didn't
bother to download it that's the only
thing i think that as more people become
acquainted with 2b i think that's going
to be the place to go to to place a film
and i've actually been in talks with
them so that i don't have to go through
an aggregator in order to place films
there because all they really want to
see is that they're not dealing with a
filmmaker who has one film they want to
deal with someone who has multiple films
so that they aren't just dealing with
one offs of having to have different
bank accounts to pay or whatever so
that's why they deal with aggregators
that's why they deal with distributors
because they're just paying
one person for a lot of films versus
one-offs so you don't have let's say a
dashboard within
2b that you can go and see what you made
for this quarter
i don't have it because i don't have a
direct relationship with them yet but
i'm about to have a direct relationship
with them
for right now i see all of my revenue
projections from filmhub
okay right
why do you place such an emphasis on
owning your own movies
i believe that that is the only way to
operate with any type of freedom in this
industry
to be tethered to
a committee to be tethered to someone
who holds the purse strings
it just
already this
this industry you have to have a thick
skin already
and it's an artistic industry it's not
like it's
you know being an accountant or
something it's it's actually
you
relying on your own creativity and your
ability to
take what's ever in your head and apply
it
in reality to make it come true right
you're trying to do all these things and
and ultimately you have so many people
around you that are
that could be whether it's negatively or
positively influenced in that and
manipulating it and they don't mean to
they don't mean to it's not like i don't
think many people are out to just screw
you over with bad ideas i think that
everybody just wants their own thing
they want their own imprint on whatever
it is
and
it really hampers your your freedom and
your ability to grow but if you
if you were able to finance your own
projects and you were able to understand
the distribution process so that you
understand how much money you generate
from that
then
you've taken so much of your own
financial freedom and your creative
freedom into your own hands
that's why i really emphasize owning
your own rights and
not i don't even license my stuff out
unless i know that this person can do
something that i can't do
and even then i'm only licensing the
rights to them for the things that i
can't do on my own
that's it
because i know that if i license as a
license and to them for
i don't know
two three years that's two or three
years that i'm tied to them on this
specific thing and if i learn how to do
that in that specific in that during
that time i can't even do anything about
it because they're already doing it so i
have to wait until their license is up
before i can do it myself because i like
to i like holding me accountable i like
making myself responsible because that's
the only way i know for sure 100 that it
will get done
and get done to
the level that i would do it or that i
want it to be done
so
in all of this what i'm trying to do is
take all of my projects and use them to
not only express myself artistically but
also to provide my own security moving
forward
you know
you